hi drew this is archana from ministry of  curry and i'm going to show you how to  make delicious butter chicken in the  instant pot set the instant pot to saute  more and heat two tablespoons of ghee  and a cup of diced onion two teaspoons  of salt saute this for two to three  minutes add a tablespoon each of ginger  and garlic half a teaspoon of turmeric  two teaspoons of red chili powder one  teaspoon of garam masala  half a cup of water and a cup of tomato  puree add two pounds of chicken thighs  and give a good stir pressure cook this  for eight minutes  stir in half a cup of cream  two tablespoons of tomato paste and a  teaspoon of sugar two tablespoons of  dried fenugreek leaves  cook on saute more as you get a nice  thick  creamy curry enjoy  you